hi we're at the VMAs you have been very
hard at work so first let's talk about
the new comedy Dickenson yes the teaser
judge is gonna say trailer that is
coming the teaser drop today and I've
kind of been in that in that time where
all my friends are like so you've
mentioned that you were working on that
show for a long time and my fans are
like where have you been and what are
you doing are you lying so thank you no
it's so good to have a little sneak peek
of the show finally out it's something
that really means a lot to me on so many
different levels and this is a story
from I mean the perspective of one of
the greatest female American poets ever
and it's wild and it's funny and it's
weird and it's it's a little bit of
everything so I'm very excited about it
and we would be a miss at the VMAs if we
didn't ask you about new music I saw
that you posted you were in the studio
so was that for like maybe a theme song
to that or what are we having a new
record coming might be one or the other
could be both I have been working on the
music non-stop and I'm so excited I feel
like it's it's just been weirdly so I
finished season one of Dickinson and I
went straight home to LA and I've been
writing ever since and I think that I
kind of had this new sort of perspective
on writing after playing this character
just this sort of fearlessness that I've
never really approached my writing with
so I'm very excited about this new music
it's very honest it's very fun and it's
coming soon okay tell me about the looks
the looks so this is as old sis Kelsey
it's this is Adam Vic and if you tell
you a secret
so there's bees all over it right if and
when you watch all of season one of
Dickinson's yeah you will see that there
is a slight little tiny egg like the
week I don't know how many more Easter
eggs that I can like figure out with the
Taylor Swift record and now the bees on
the dresser everywhere um did you get a
chance to see Taylor open oh my god of
course of course I saw it on a small
screen because I went out right after
her but I mean I will be rewatching that
over and over and over again she's
incredible the new record is absolutely
and yeah that performance was what
better way to kick off the VMAs
[Music]